parler un petit peu sérieusement laurent
ruquier cartonne toujours la reprenne a
dit loin devant en tête julien courbet
bon on a mis aussi qui cartonne voilà je
le dis franchement julien cart m6 et les
il n'y a rien à dire voilà julien et
laurent cartonne voilà après france
apparaît s'avère qu'elles servent elles
débouchent ils sont malheureusement et
je dis malheureusement parce que je peux
qu'rtl de redevienne première à d'autres
en sont malheureusement deuxième et je
voudrais dire europe 1 vous allez voir
ça va remonter parce que j'aime aussi
cette radio europe 1 on m'a donné ma
chance et qui sont les gens formidables
là bas ils entendent vraiment elle a un
ça va finir par remonter vous savez aime
et vous lire c'est comme dans une joute
est un truc dans l'eau un moment tu vas
voir ça et je serai toujours derrière
europe 1 parce que c'est des gens
formidables en tout cas et je peux vous
dire ils vont souvent souvent idée donc
voilà bravo
il s'appelle est ce que vous pouvez dire
quelque chose qu'on pouvait avouer que
rtl et deuxième radio de france s'il
vous plaît il faut le dire un mot à
lézat non mais nous voulons sortir sans
pleurer mais oui c'est comme si c'est
des chiffres
bailly c'est la vérité le pantalon plus
tôt non non vous en perdez pas méchant
mais c'est un registre a menacé nicolas
selouane président dira t elle est ici
nous le patron de l'invs et nicolas
tavernier leur président de tous
totalement convient oui mais ce que vous
êtes vous êtes vous êtes ben oui parce
que la renommée vous êtes bien faut le
dire à être confiant tout ce dont vous
êtes combien elle a ajouté que la
première radio france la première radio
de france sur beaucoup de sueur beaucoup
à l'équipe
oui c'est fair-play c'est simon les
aider
la première celle de france et ça mais
porsche le culot de dire c'était fait
nous on a gagné dans laissez vous tenter
38 mille auditeurs encore ordonner de le
dire bal à la salle et la première dame
je vais faire comme bernard et comme
steven il n'ya pas bricoler la première
d'autrui alors en ce moment oui sur
lesquels à illzach ça ne sortait pas
plusieurs jours et je pense que ça mais
c'est passé le dire tout bêtement pas
voilà bah oui en ce moment en france un
verre actualité oblige et première à
deux fois
[Applaudissements]
très bien calmes et radio de france et
je suis pas comment ouf non plus
inquiets ces êtres une chef
oui puisque nagui et toros moi j'écoute
walaja cnac et aguiche au comptant et
antoine le connais parce que je livre à
l'arrêt stop ça vanne de caunes et sonia
devillers elle progresse se sentent pas
d'amis